as Israel continues its Complete Siege
and bombing of Gaza in an upfront
special we discuss how the war is being
presented in the west and whether there
is any hope for
ceasefire following hamas's deadly
October 7th attack that claimed the
lives of more than a thousand Israelis
including hundreds of civilians Israel
retaliated heavily bombing the Gaza
Strip while much of the West expressed
solidarity with Israel asserting its
right to self-defense
human rights groups have also condemned
Israel's disproportionate response more
than 4,000 people including hundreds of
children have been killed and at least 1
million displaced which raises concerns
about potential violations of
international law with tensions running
High violence has spread outside of Gaza
with attacks against Palestinians in the
West Bank and islamophobic and
anti-semitic attacks on the rise
globally joining us to discuss this all
in Tel Aviv is hagay matar executive
director of plus 972 magazine in
Philadelphia not eat a human rights law
scholar and associate professor at rers
University and here in studio with me is
laa Friedman president of the foundation
for Middle East peace thank you all for
joining me uh ha guy I'm going to start
with you uh we've seen the dire
situation in Gaza schools and hospitals
destroyed residents struggling to get
basic necessities I mean water for
example but violence against
Palestinians has drastically risen in
the occupied West Bank at least 58
Palestinian have been killed since
October 7th and there are reports that
two Villages have been depopulated the
situation has become increasingly
unsustainable for Palestinians at least
229 Palestinians have been killed since
the beginning of this year can you talk
about the reasons behind this escalation
of violence and and particularly in the
West
Bank yes of course um well we're getting
reports even as we speak about
additional communities that are being
displaced in ethnically lands so we were
seeing a move by the settlers a very
intentional move to capture on the fact
that U the world's attention is on Gaza
right now and that Israel is getting so
much solidarity um and support from the
world that nobody would care and the
facto we're seeing settlers day after
day night after night attacking
Palestinian communities and really
pushing them out destroying entire uh
villages so so that is happening as we
speak uh like you said over 60 people
killed but it's less of um a new
beginning just an escalation of what
we've seen in recent years and
especially over the past year with
Israeli government really giving a free
hand for settlers to attack Palestinian
communities the pattern is usually of
settlers attacking a Palestinian
Community they're accompanied by
soldiers they would set fire to
Palestinian houses or cars or just uh
attack people and if Palestinians try to
defend themselves by throwing stones um
the Army would jump in and start
shooting at the people who are defending
themselves often killing Palestinians
we've seen a lot of that in recent days
but also over the past year um and that
is a culmination of about two years of
escalating violence in the West Bank the
PA is essentially nonfunctional is not
offering Palestinians any defense the
Israeli Army and police are not offering
Palestinian any defense um and settlers
are becoming more and more emboldened in
these attacks well at the same time the
Army itself is also attacking uh
invading Palestinian cities in the West
Bank uh and this is a pattern that we've
seen escalate over the past uh two years
nor it's not just that the Israeli
government is watching as settlers are
engaging in uh more intensified acts of
violence and more frequent acts of
violence uh Israeli National Security
Minister idar bin gavier said on Tuesday
that Israel began distributing
distributing assault rifles to civilian
sec security teams that's the language
they use civilian security teams inside
of settlements uh what does that mean
and how does that uh Bode when we think
about deescalation peace agreements
stability uh any of these things I think
that it's important to put this in a
broader context of what Israel has done
and its settler colonization efforts and
I think that we should be mindful that
in this situation what is happening is
an ongoing bid to remove Palestinian
from their homes not just since ' 67 but
since Israel's establishment in 1948 and
to replace them with settlers this is
happening obviously in the West Bank
it's happening in the ethnic cleansing
of the villages in the judaization known
as ethnic cleansing in Jerusalem it is
happening in the south of of Israel in
the nakab and it's happening through
Warfare in the Gaza Strip by removing
Palestinians the forest population
transfer the shrink thinking of the
perimeter of the coastal Enclave in
order to take more land without the
people Lara this picture that Norah is
painting makes us far more complicated
than just a war that will begin and end
she's talking about a historic process
she's talking about a settler Colonial
project uh that seems to have the
sanction not just of the state but in
some ways maybe the global Community
what do you make of that look I think if
you understand what's happening in Gaza
through the lens of Israel trying to
exactly what what what Norah said trying
to shrink The Enclave trying to get more
Palestinians out and take more land if
you look at what's happening in the West
Bank the violence that Hagi is talking
about isn't random we are we're in the
process of finally clearing out
Palestinians from area C which is 60% of
the West Bank um you know Danny sideman
who's who's talked for years about the
the the part of the Israeli public which
wants to finish the 1948 War they say
there is no Israeli Palestinian conflict
the 1948 War isn't done and finishing it
means establishing and and completing
Israeli sovereignty over all the land
between the river and the Sea and that
means depopulating of Palestinians as
best one can and limiting the presence
and the rights um of those that you
can't move Nora in recent years we saw
some progress uh some push back against
the conditions that you're describing uh
then October 7th happens and it feels
like in many ways
we've been reset that we're back to
square one again we're we're literally
seeing media
representations where people are
attending a ceasefire Rally or a pro
Palestinian rights Rally or something
designed to stop the violence that we
see right now and fight for justice and
we've seen media Outlets refer to them
as Pro Hamas rallies or pro-isis rallies
we've seen uh misinformation
disinformation spread in ways that
undermines Free Speech rights for the
people doing the
protesting how do you what role does the
media play in in escalation
here I think that the media um the
mainstream media has abdicated its
responsibility and journalistic
integrity in order to report to question
to investigate to ask really hard
questions instead they have been
propagating what seems to be a US
Government line a US government that has
provided unequivocal support Financial
military economic to Israel that has
used its veto power now the 44th veto to
undermine In This Moment a ceasefire and
historically to undermine an
international resolution in any
accountability to Israel and rather than
a a media core exercising its
journalistic skills and responsibility
in order to push back and to push hard
we see them propagating these lies we
see them actually fomenting violence and
War by using using islamophobic tropes
by building on the infrastructure of the
war on terror by running headlines that
this is a hostage crisis as opposed to a
political crisis by describing this as a
war between Israel and Gaza or Israel
and Hamas when in fact this is a war
against all Palestinians and a
continuing process the F the the mere
fact no let me let me interrupt you for
a second because in addition to the
ethical and moral dimensions of this uh
from a legal perspective you're
international human rights attorney H
how culpable are media Outlets
potentially if they run a story or
headline or make a claim that foments
violence they are very culpable I made
this point yesterday um when we were
looking at what the BBC the BBC ran a
headline uh 24 hours before the bombing
of the alahi hospital that said do does
Hamas run tunnels underneath hospitals
and schools immediately what triggered
for me is a rem you know a point to
remind the journalistic core that the
genocide convention holds individuals to
account not merely for the commitment of
genocide but for genocidal intent for
aiding it for being complicit in it by
running that headline by perpetuating
this idea that there are no Palestinian
civilians as the president Isaac Herzog
said without pushing back as accepting
without criticism the genocidal intent
that was our articulated by the Israeli
minister of defense that Palestinians
are human animals and they will complete
impose a Complete Siege preventing the
access of water and electricity and
humanitarian corridors they are actually
being complicit he guy help me
understand this from within the Israeli
and Palestinian context you're on the
ground uh are we seeing similar
opposition to Pro Palestinian voices yes
definitely but I want to start slightly
before that with the effects of the
October seventh attack um I do think
that there's it broke something very
essential in the discourse um there's a
huge challenge that we're facing right
now I mean the very real reality of uh
Palestinians massacring hundreds of uh
unarmed Israeli civilians at uh field
where there was just a dance party um
people that were murdered stuttered in
their homes I mean that reality with you
know over 1300 victims most of them
civilians um I think it's it's only
natural it only makes sense that for a
lot of people there would be this
feeling of we have supported you know
the pal struggle or the struggle for
justice uh but now it's making it much
more difficult to support and and this
is something we all need to contend with
how do we create or sustain a discourse
about Palestinian Justice and about
Palestinian Liberation and about
resisting apartheid and at the same time
uh being consecutive in rejecting these
war crimes against Israelis I think that
complexity is missing in so many spaces
leading amongst them Israeli is the
Israeli discourse where of course the
only prevailing narrative and this
connects to what Nora is saying is we
are only the victims see what they're
doing to us we are only the victims here
uh we're only defending ourselves and
that reality uh is leading to to what
we're seeing now on the ground which is
persecution of anyone saying anything
that is the slightest um critical of the
government so that reality alongside
dozens of Palestinians who have been
arrested fired or suspended from
universities in Israel um that is part
of the persecution that's happening
because there's absolutely no room for
criticism of the government policies
following October 7 um on Wednesday
Molotov cocktails were H at a synagogue
in the center of Berlin and there have
been reports of swastikas spray painted
at schools and on buildings in the
United States L incidents like these
have certainly increased since October
7th uh do you foresee this getting worse
so I I don't I don't know about the data
in the United States on incidents like
these in the United States increasing
there has been um incidents of anti-
Palestinian violence in the United
States including a six-year-old child
stabbed to death in Chicago including
someone in Michigan arrested because he
advertised who want to come with me to
Dearborn and I think he said hunt
Palestinians um we've seen videos online
of of raging people raging against
Palestinian protesters in ways that if
they did this against um pro-israel
protesters they would be certainly
arrested it would be called
anti-Semitism do do do you also
implicate the media in that and and
specifically what you're talking about
was Saturday the 14th the Palestinian
mother and son were stabbed in Illinois
by their landlord the six-year-old boy
was stabbed 26 times later dying of his
wounds uh and Detectives detered
determined that the mother and son were
targeted in light of them quote being
Muslim and the ongoing Middle Eastern
conflict involving Hamas and the
Israelis this is from the police uh what
role does the media play in making this
stuff the media plays a tremendous role
I believe the rest of that article says
that that the wife said that her husband
was was taken over by these ideas
because of watching right-wing media the
the the challenge here when we talk
about anti-Semitism in the same
conversation we're talking about Gaza or
anti-palestinian ism is that for years
those who want to shut down criticism of
Israel um advocacy for Palestinian
rights have argued that it is a form of
anti-Semitism right and throughout even
the Trump era when we did have actual
surging anti-Semitism coming from you
know fascists and Nazis right classic
anti-Semitism you know people who the
people who are supposed to be taken care
of and fighting anti-Semitism always
made sure to say and left and the right
as if there's some some equivalence
because when we start talking about
anti-Semitism the argument that I've
made for years is if you are blaming all
Jews for the actions of Israel that is
anti-Semitic at the same time Defenders
of Israel are saying if you do not
recognize that defense of Palestinians
is criticism of Jews that Jews in Israel
for this context are indistinguishable
that's anti-Semitism and I I worry with
the incredible surging violence that
we're seeing right now as the the the
organized Jewish Community the
government of Israel the government of
the United States frames this explicitly
as attacks on Jews that that disagreeing
with what Israel is doing in Gaza is an
attack on the Jewish people I worry that
there's going to be blowback absolutely
that isn't because the fight for
Palestinian rights is intrinsically
anti-semitic it's because those who want
to defend Israel from criticism are are
insisting that you cannot distinguish
between Jews and Israel that that
worries me tremendously it's interesting
Nota because it seems that the West
particularly dominant Western Nations
have one
disposition about human rights
violations about illegal actions for
most countries and then when it comes to
Palestine there seems to be an
exception I give you an example since
the October 7th attack by Hamas uh a
majority of Western Powers have stood in
support of Israel now I want to Jose
that to 2022 when the president of the
European commission Ursula vandan gave a
speech calling out Russia's targeting of
Ukrainian civilians let's have a listen
targeted attacks on civilian
infrastructure with a clear aim to cut
off men women children of water
electricity and heating with the winter
coming these are acts of pure Terror and
we have to call it as such you know
they're saying these
attacks cutting off electricity all this
stuff is inexcusable it's illegal etc
etc and yet these very same Nations
these very same forces who have stood up
uh when it was Russia Ukraine are now
not just complicit in their silence they
are actively supporting Israel's
response you know I think in this moment
we have to contend with the fact that we
are not in a postcolonial reality but
the colonialism cont continues to shape
Our Lives it's in the same way that
genocide was practiced um
very much before it was prescribed in
1949 but it was never recognized when it
was committed by Colonial Powers against
brown and black peoples but it becomes
recognized when it was practiced within
Europe's borders there is a continuing
Colonial reality that is shaping how
Palestinians have been excluded even
from the judical category of the
civilian one that Echoes uh American
jurists in their genocide IAL Warfare
against Native Americans who have
articulated that Native Americans are
savages and to whom the laws of war even
dating back to the Liber code the first
articulation of humanitarian law um
during the Civil War excluded Native
Americans from the category of civilians
that made their Massacre plausible and
so we need to remember we are still
existing in that Colonial reality one in
which these former Colonial powers and
in some cases ongoing Colonial powers
have excluded Palestinians from this
category and have found it far easier
and more morally compatible with their
uh lack of principle to support Israel
in genocidal Warfare than it has been to
support Palestinians in an ongoing
decolonization struggle he guy H how is
international support uh being viewed
inside of Israel from these various
countries particularly the United States
well it seem as exactly what it is a
green light to do what whatever this
government wants to do uh it's not it's
both International supports of course
you know the US with its aircraft
carriers and and Fleet um mored just
outside of Israel um is is a significant
part of that the international support
is a part of that and picking up on what
Laro was saying you can see these you
know very heartfelt speeches by
President Biden saying you know that he
wants to reassure Israelis of their
Safety and Security and that they have a
future and they have allies uh and
that's beautiful that's great but at the
same time you you realize that what that
means is that he's not saying the same
things to Palestinians he's not telling
the dozens of Palestinian families that
were wiped out in Gaza he's not telling
their relatives your lives matter and we
want to protect you as well we're
telling Israelis that their lives matter
and they can do to you whatever they
want that is what Israelis are picking
up from this I think that is what Biden
means and that's how it's being utilized
so I want want you all to give me your
your best insights what are the chances
of a ceasefire and not I'll start with
you I just want to start by saying that
before I got onto this program I asked
you know several people to help me just
search for the names of the Palestinians
who were massacred in the AL hospital I
think that there has been part of the
dehumanization project aside from the
fact that we're getting clear that
there's no principle that all civilian
life is is sacred but aside from that
the fact that Palestinian death toll is
just shared with us in astonishing
numbers in ways that are actually
dehumanizing Palestinians because we are
not getting the extent of pain for each
life lost we are not getting the extent
of pain of all the beloveds and the kin
that are watching this and being
traumatized of the babies who are left
without any family around them who are
to wake up to a world orphaned and
abandoned by the world that is blaming
them for their own misery and only
proposing to them that we're going to
keep you in tighter cages in order to
resolve this issue so here I just want
to emphasize to an audience watching you
know at what number will trigger the
horror that should have been triggered
already of Palestinian death is it
10,000 is it a 100,000 we have been
asking this question since the
debilitating Siege was imposed on the
Gaza Strip and so the fact that we can't
see that number within any plain site
speaks the Deep dehumanization the
racial discourse the colonial discourse
that has basically primed audiences to
accept Palestinian death and slow death
as tragic but necessary which is
obscuring the fact back to your question
mark where is where is the ceasefire
regardless of you know this red herring
of who bombed the hospital there should
be an unequivocal call because of the
horror and the atrocity for an immediate
ceasefire Israel has done enough it
killed 16 paramedics it has denied
electricity to hospitals where children
babies cannot survive in incubators
because of a la a lack of electricity it
has cut off water it is carpon bombed
humanitarian convoys that are trying to
travel to the South that's not enough
that now it becomes necessary to debate
whether or not this was actually an
Israeli air strike if there's really the
fog of war is making everything unclear
then lift the fog and impose an
immediate ceasefire why did the US veto
that resolution in the security Council
proposed by Brazil so this this is where
we're at and I I urge all all viewers
that at this point a ceasefire is the
bare minimum and absolutely necessary
nor erat says ha guy is it
likely I'm afraid not I completely agree
with Nora it is necessary I think C Fire
release of the civilian captives um that
Hamas is holding um and then moving on
to negotiations to first release the
rest of the of the prisoners of War on
both sides all of this is absolutely
necessary Paving the way for future
negotiations as well it is highly
unlikely if there was any hope at all of
a Biden visit putting limits on Israel's
use of force saying you know forget it
forget it grounded there's been enough
death enough suffering uh you need to
stop now we've actually seen the
opposite and therefore it is quite
likely now that Israel will go ahead
with a planned ground Invasion that
could take days that could take weeks um
and ceasefire seems further way now than
it did um for the past week or so is
that your sense too lar so I'm going to
give a slightly longer answer as well um
as someone who's been watching the
Israeli um political narrative evolve
over over decades and and the the
growing um normalization of the Far Far
Right kahanist narrative this is the the
this is essentially the the the
narrative which says Palestinians This
Is Our Land the Palestinians should
never have been here they are obstacles
to our state they must be removed um and
that is where the mainstream is I think
very much in Israel today where you see
with this government um there are
officials with this this Israeli
government that are talking very clearly
about taking land about cutting the size
of the Gaza Strip when you move when you
tell a million people to leave half the
Gaza Strip I think of South Lebanon
Israel has a military Doctrine which
says we fight people on their land not
ours it is inconceivable to me that
Israel will stop this before they have
laid the ground or for them to stay
permanently in a depopulated part of
Gaza you have language about trying to
get humanitarian corridors humanitarian
is in quotes here out of Gaza into the
SI people need to think about what that
means that is a basically talk talking
about setting up the equivalent of
prison camps for Palestinians in the
desert and maybe they'll be able to
bribe cc into doing that but that's
that's the goal here I don't think
you're going to get a ceasefire until
Israel has accomplished whatever goals
they've decided I don't think their
endgame is explicitly clear and the last
thing I want to say when we say a
ceasefire is the bare minimum let's be
clear based on what has already done if
there was a ceasefire today the
humanitarian catastrophe that has been
caused in Gaza will take years just on a
humanitarian basis to recover from so
ceasefire is not the end of the game but
my God it is a bare minimum if you have
any sense of humanity Freedman ha mat
not eat thank you so much for joining me
everyone that is our show up front we'll
be back next
[Music]
week